we're joined Now by Louise Brooks whose
uh brother Andrew Mark Brooks died in
the Hillsborough disaster thank you so
much for for joining us Louise um uh
we'll perhaps come to the government and
the Home Secretary who we just heard of
in a moment but but firstly to the
police and and what they said today
they've apologized for profound failings
which they said continued to blight
relatives of victims like like you what
do you what do you make of that
I don't think it's sincere at all to be
honest with you
um you know I've read the report it's
more nervously not word for word
um I've read quite a bit of it though
and
um I feel that until
actions change at top level you know I
ranking officers Chief constables
um and they're made accountable I don't
think anything will ever change within
the Police Service I think my main issue
has always been that the reason why
some of these police officers go to the
lengths that they go to to to lie and
cover up and to
um not ever be held accountable for
their actions or lack of actions is
because they know that they are
protected by their forces the government
you know the establishment just protect
them and so it's not in their interest
to actually
um
tell the truth
you mentioned too little too late and
and clearly it's over three decades
since uh since you lost your brother
what about sit more simply the Gap since
the report came out since 2017 but what
could it explain a six-year Gap in
responding to that
well you know I was going to say that
there's just no excuse that quite
frankly I was expecting them to to blame
kovid on it to be honest with you but
um obviously they haven't
um
how many more reports do they need to
release I know there's going to be
another report released which quite
frankly I don't want released
um
I think that all these reports it just
takes us family three families and
survivors back we all try and move on
with their lives but we're not able to
um because obviously there's always
something around the corner again
um
I I just would like the you know
people to be able to accountable when
they've done wrong and I think that's
all the public want you know is just to
put your hands up and admit you've done
wrong
um
I think it's just the lies and the
continuous lies but it's also that they
are then allowed to retire on a police
pension and you know some even continue
you know to work for the police
um
I just think it's outrageous and I think
I have police force
is
a National Disgrace I really do and what
what I would like to add is there are a
lot of good police officers they are not
all bad at all but the problem you have
is
the bad ones
represent the good ones and it takes it
it's going to take a lot I feel for
a police service
to
be respected again because there's
something coming out every single week
every single day about corruption with
you know within the police well I mean
it's certainly hard to argue about the
two little too late point in terms of
accountability I guess the police might
suggest that's what they're trying to
bring with with this this statement
today I wanted to move on if I could
um uh with the government and we just
heard from Sue Ella bravaman I mean
clearly we still haven't had their
official response to the the 2017
reports well Bravo and the Home
Secretary just said the timing they want
to avoid the risk of prejudice and any
ongoing criminal investigations but the
government quote is absolutely committed
to responding to the Bishops report as
soon as practical what do you make of
that six years on
well let's just see how long it takes
now for that report to be uh written
um from today shall we let's just see
how serious and genuine
um they really are still no apology from
them no deck don't forget
um it's David Cameron who accused us of
being blind people in a dark room
looking for a black cat and also we were
accused
um by the then Chief Constable
um David Crompton have been Liars you
know we we were the ones who have been
accused of being Liars
um in terms of uh what you'd like to see
from here there was one uh aspect going
back to the police force where they've
said an updated code of ethics uh we'll
see them police officers trained uh in
Canada to prevent a repeat of lies and
cover-ups uh that followed the tragedy
in April 1989. I was going to ask for
your reaction but I can I guess I can
read it on your face
it's love for bullies in it really I
mean
I why do you have to be trained to be an
honest person
um I wasn't trained to be an honest
person
um that's what a decent human being is
you are naturally honest caring and
compassionate and
um those are the traits which they have
never ever shown us three families or
survivors and I think um just going back
to that and just to to Hillsborough law
um
I didn't campaign for else below because
um I didn't believe and I still don't
believe Hillsborough will ever happen
you know it should happen but it won't
because the establishment goes to all
lengths to protect themselves and it's
not in the establishments
um interest to other Hillsborough but my
other thing is that
if you've got a person not necessarily
just a police officer but anybody who
goes to into a courtroom and they do not
want to tell the truth
they will not tell the truth but the
thing for me in relation to being a
police officer
when you know that you are going to be
protected by your force and by the
government
it's not in your interest to tell the
truth and that's one thing why I think
that
Chief constables should be owed to
account more
and I think until things change and much
higher level I don't think we'll start
to see the changes at the lower levels
and I think that the lower levels know
that they're protected so much that
they know they can just get away with
anything really well Louise Brooks we
thank you very much for joining us today